San Francisco 49ers nailed down the NFC
West championship at the tail end of the
week 17 game against the Seattle
Seahawks barely holding off Seattle but
nevertheless taking the division and
ultimately heading to the Superbowl best
division in football right now with
Seattle the Rams and the Arizona
Cardinals chasing the 49ers what have
those teams done to narrow the gap which
really is kind of narrow anyway when you
consider how hard it was for the 49ers
to fend off the Seattle Seahawks and
let's start with what the 49ers did guys
what I mean I you know divorce Buckner
being traded to the Colts was kind of a
surprise one of the key players on the
defensive line but they have done what
they had to do to replace him in round
one with Devon Kinlaw and then the
receiver they added trading up to get
Brandon a ook as Chris said last week
this is this is the guy that Kyle
Shanahan wanted this is the guy he
viewed as the top receiver to fit that
offense Peter I think that for a team
that you know has nowhere to go but down
they have done a pretty good job of
treading water right where they are
about John Lynch had the best week of
anybody any general manager any
franchise architect imagine that all
along you're thinking I have two jobs in
this draft I've got to replace the
forest Bugner and I've got to get a
franchise receiver and then on Tuesday
imagine Kyle Shanahan calls Joe Staley
and says hey just want to get an update
on what you're thinking and Staley then
telling him and John Lynch I'm gonna
retire so now you don't have to big
things to do in the draft you have three
and by the way oh just go find the left
tackle by the way so what does he do he
not only gets the the defensive tackle
Kinlaw and the wide receiver I you in
the draft but he trades a five and next
year's three so the value essentially is
for a four and a five you get for at
least one year a guy who's gonna be
almost as good as any left tackle in
football who knows what happens after
one year but John Lynch solved all three
problems on one weekend I just thought
the 49ers had a tremendous draft weekend
yeah they definitely did I mean they
killed it they would be one of the teams
I would look at yes where it wasn't a
ton of draft picks that jump out to you
like some other teams but it's the
quality of the draft picks to what Peter
say you know I still wonder in this
whole thing like would Chris Ballard
have traded it away the 13th pick for
DeForest Buckner if he knew Javon Kinlaw
was gonna fall to him at 13 I would love
to know the answer to that because I
have the greatest respect to the Chris
Dollard at how he builds a football team
but you know you guys hit on all of it
you know I just think again it just
shows the leadership of Kyle Shanahan
you know and John Lynch John Lynch the
GM but let's not forget Shanahan is the
one like Bill Belichick who has last
rites and he's the one that makes these
calls it shows how good they are at
running an organization to me
specifically with the Trent Williams
situation to be able to keep it quiet
with Joe Staley not have anybody know
not hurt their trade leverage and
getting this awesome Hall of Fame left
tackle from the Washington Redskins
where we know it was a delicate
situation because Dan Snyder's not a big
fan of the channel family and I think
the feeling is probably mutual to get
that done I just think shows that the
49ers are one of those teams that we
talked about yesterday Mike they're in
the ten where you better watch out
they're doing things and have a clue an
organizational goal every year and
they're they're special that way go
ahead Peter
Mike can I add one thing to what Chris
said and that is that so everybody after
the draft when I wrote my piece from
inside the virtual war room of the books
the biggest comment I had is boy why did
Jason light had to have to give up his
fourth round pick to move one spot when
he knew that he was still gonna get
Tristan worth just sit there at 14
instead of trading up with the Niners
and you know that would make a lot of
sense in all years except one and that's
this year because light told me after
the draft we had some Intel that Joe
Staley might be retiring
either that or where he was gonna retire
that he was very very close to the end
and they also knew this is not something
I wrote but they knew John Lynch
confirmed it to me yesterday they really
like Tristan worse not that they were
going to take Tristan worse at 13 they
were gonna take Javon kinloch but and
but they knew the Bucks knew that there
was interest in San Francisco interest
in worse and that's why in essence they
ended up having to make the trade okay
so we've established the 49ers had a
great weekend to already add to a great
team the Seahawks all in all free agency
and the draft have they done enough to
catch and maybe surpass the 49 is the
added linebacker Jordan Brooks in round
one they've gotten rid of a couple of
offensive linemen they've added
offensive lineman do we see enough of an
elevation of the Seahawks organization
Chris to give them a chance to stay as
close as they already were the 49ers I
do think so I mean I think they made the
appropriate moves in free agency to to
go along with that you know let's not
forget you know Mike I you potty there
to help the offensive line Greg Olsen
you know Cedric ablai he Phillip Dorsett
trading for Quinton Dunbar from the
Washington Redskins who's a really good
scheme set fit for them Bruce Urban's
back to come off the edge and then Mike
you mentioned it the draft picks hey
Jordan Brooks is a Bobby Wagner type
talent that's what he is and he'll be
the replacement for Bobby Wagner at some
point but then getting it yes a
second-round edge guy and Darrell Taylor
from Tennessee who's going to be a
really fine player so yeah I do think
Seattle has you know closed the gap a
little bit certainly Seattle was a team
that even through this winning process
is still kind of rebuilding their team
from that Super Bowl era team that we
saw so again I think John Schneider and
Pete Carroll have certainly closed the
gap a little why the 49ers have done a
great job to Peter your thoughts on the
Seahawks
yeah I'm sorry Mike my biggest thought
is that you know I don't agree with
Chris altogether I think that the 49ers
really set themselves up
as the premier team in this division not
that the Seahawks didn't do anything but
in my opinion they have tried forever to
fix the offensive line maybe they will
but that's just gonna be just gonna be
something I think we're all gonna have
to see first and I don't think the
Seahawks are done I think sometime in
the next week or so they wait out
Jadeveon Clowney and Everson Griffin
they sign one of those guys because this
is still a team that absolutely still
needs another piece in that pass rush
they can't count on Bruce Irvin to to be
better than he ever has and the only way
that they're pass rush today is great is
if Bruce Irvin is a 15 sack guy I don't
see that in that defense right now I
think they end up by the time the games
are being played they end up with either
clowny or Griffin and then they're gonna
have a representative tough good pass
rush you know you know and I'm not
forgetting all the other guys that they
have in their locker room you know
obviously they made a lot of noise last
year getting rid of a Frank Clark and
everything and they replaced him was
sort of more of a budget conscious look
and just my thought is that I think San
Francisco they're very close anyway but
I think San Francisco and what the 49ers
have done is they've distanced
themselves from the rest of the division
between the Rams and the Cardinals guys
and I'll start with Chris on this which
of the two teams is closest to breaking
out of the bottom of the division and
challenging the top of the division if
we accept that it's the 49ers and the
Seahawks in those top two spots wow it's
really close I mean Arizona has made
some big time boobs as we all know
through the draft and in free agency
they did I mean you know some of the
free agent signings Jordan Phillips
defensive tackle for Buffalo Devon Dre
Campbell you know getting him at
linebacker along with Isaiah Simmons in
this draft so now the second level of
their defense is going to be much
improved
you know Hopkins to that offense DeAndre
Hopkins is going to be huge but
I'm not gonna lie guys I really like
what the Rams have done this offseason
I mean first off I think the Rams kind
of secretly killed the draft they got
their Todd Gurley replacement and cam
akers got another really awesome
receiver in van Jefferson Terrell Lewis
I don't think the Alabama edge rusher he
was one of my top five head brushers
bike I mean he has a chance to be a
superstar you know my comparison was
like Jonathan Abram who ended up with
John Abram ember and him he ended up
with like Abraham twenty one hundred and
thirtysomething Sachs career wise you
know they took a shot on him in the
third round because he was injured a
little in college you know and then you
talk about Leonard Floyd and getting
back Michael brokers at a Sean Robertson
now I think the Rams quietly made some
big-time moves yeah they lost some names
and some star power and girly and clay
Mathews but those are guys number
they're you know they're not the same
guys that we used to know them as and
III quietly think Sean McVeigh let's
need have done a really good job this
offseason Mike I'm gonna be very
surprised if the Arizona Cardinals are
not a 500 team or better very surprised
and I don't think any team in the NFL in
this offseason so far has added of the
magnitude of somebody on offense and
somebody on defense as DeAndre Hopkins a
top three receiver in the NFL and Isaiah
Simmons who can play five positions and
in my opinion sort of rekindles what the
old Todd Bowles Cardinals used to do
which is to take a guy and make him from
being a strong saftey and put him down
in the box sometimes move them all over
the formation you saw with Tyrann
Mathieu start with day on B can and you
know and you look at what the Cardinals
have done and I think that in helping
Kyler Murray the way they have and they
still have a very effective Larry
Fitzgerald
you know Christian Kirk in my opinion I
think they're gonna be a dangerous
offense and I think they're going to be
a much improved defense and as I say
it's gonna be tough to win eight games
this year in that division I think
that's right Cardinals do it
something that that Chris and I have
kicked around in the past Peter and this
is tied to the scheduling formula this
year the NFC West teams play all four
teams from the AFC East all four teams
from the NFC East with an extra
wild-card spot available do not be
flabbergasted if all four teams from the
NFC West are in playoff contention late
and there's a way the dominoes fall
where all four of those teams get into
the postseason in the first year of
seven spots per cover
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports